how's it working with somebody like Shia
LaBeouf
leboof you know I love that I love Shia
he's uh clearly
insanely talented um
[Music]
and uh I think misunderstood a lot I
think that he gets a bad rap I think he
does have
you know when he's not drinking he's
much more yeah level and I think that
he'd probably be the first one to admit
it um but he you know he I just I I I've
known him since he was
a kid you know the first the first
Transformers movie
I'll never forget he's just such a wild
card and that's what methink makes him
so great is he shows up at LAX we're
flying to Mexico and whites or
Alamogordo New Mexico
and this I think the first time I had
actually met him and he shows up with a
black eye and we're supposed to start
shooting like two days later
I was like dude what happens like all
these punks said I was at a Dodger game
last night and these guys started
talking so I you know got I was
like he's down you can't do that man do
that but he is fearless he is truly
Fearless he's uh you know I got nothing
but love for him yeah do you keep in
touch with them uh last time I reached
out I never heard back
so I don't know I don't know I don't
know what he's up to now and then you're
currently on a in a movie with uh Mel
Gibson on Netflix yeah uh called Bandit
yeah the girl who was the uh the girl
next door next door Alicia Cuthbert yeah
yeah yeah how's it working with Mel
Gibson he's great he's the best again I
think a little bit misunderstood I know
that he's ruffled a lot of feathers over
the years with
some of the stuff that he's done and
said but uh my experience with him was
great yeah absolute gentleman
uh total Pro you know I didn't see any
of the stuff that that you hear about I
thought that he was fantastic and and by
the way one of the great I was mostly
excited to work then because he's just
one of the greatest directors of all
time if you think about some of the
stuff he's directed in Christ or
Braveheart yeah it's just like it's
insane I just wanted to pick his brain
about that like how did you do that and
at a pretty early age
yeah wow those are giant I mean buddy
games is one thing but Braveheart that's
a whole other Beast did he direct that
yeah yeah wow do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah